welcome we launched the world leaders
forum in
and three as a university-wide
initiative to support uninhibited
dialogue on the most pressing economic
political environmental and social
questions of our time questions that
with each passing year have larger and
larger global dimensions over the past
seven years the forum has offered an
opportunity for more than 15,000
students faculty and staff to directly
engage important figures from 48 nations
representing every corner of the world
our experience has confirmed the
animating principle of the world leaders
forum that only through informal
dialogue critical scholarship and a free
exchange of ideas will answers emerge to
the biggest problems facing the world
today the role of universities in
creating a space for uninhibited and
critical discussion of controversial
issues has been noted on many occasions
if anything the changes we are seen in
public discourse served to heighten the
importance of this role universities not
only are places where difficult
conversations are respected and
encouraged today it sometimes appears
that universities may be the only
remaining venues where such
conversations can take place we are now
nearly through a week of the world
leaders forum which coincide every fall
with the annual meeting of the UN
General Assembly and we've heard from a
broad and diverse group of world leaders
they have challenged us with their views
and I think it is fair to say we have
done our part in challenging them in
turn thereby we think enriching our
dialogue with the world here at Columbia
this forum offers a unique opportunity
to our students and faculty to engage in
conversations with people who are
directly involved in meeting the
challenges of the 21st century an
opportunity that would be difficult if
not impossible to replicate in any other
city or it indeed at any other
university so we are very grateful for
the heads of state and other world
leaders who continue to show their
willingness to come to columbia
university to speak and today it is my
very great pleasure and privilege to
welcome and introduce to you evil yo
sepa V
President of the Republic of Croatia
born in Zagreb he graduated from the
Faculty of Law of the university of
zagreb in 1980 where he went on to earn
his master's degree in 1985 and his PhD
in 1994 having written a thesis on the
law on arrest and pretrial detention in
Criminal Procedure law he also graduated
in composition from the Zagreb Music
Academy and holds an honorary doctorate
degree from the immanuel kant State
University of Russia prior to his
election to the office of President Evo
you also see Povich was a university
professor and so we welcome you back to
the proper context for your earlier days
he was also a member of the co asian
Parliament and a composer he taught
criminal procedure law international
penal law and misdemeanor law he also
taught harmony at the Zagreb Music
Academy he has published several books
in 85 scholarly and expert papers in
journals and magazines in Croatia as
well as abroad and is composed about 50
compositions for different instruments
chamber ensembles and symphony
orchestras that are performed by eminent
artists both within Croatia and outside
and he's received numerous artistic
prizes and awards among them the ground
prix of the european broadcasting union
and the to pour in croatian record
awards for a number of years he was also
director of one of the most important
european festivals of contemporary music
the music Biennale Zagreb and served as
Secretary General of the Croatian
composer Society president Yossi Povich
took part in the UN prep calm for the
establishment of the International
Criminal Court as well as the Rome
diplomatic conference he was an expert
on the council of europe for monitoring
prison systems in a number of countries
and as a legal expert he drafted her
code drafted a number of major
legislative bills that have passed
through in Croatia he represented
Croatia before the International
Criminal Tribunal for the former
Yugoslavia and for the International
Court of Justice he's been a steadfast
champion of human rights the rule of law
and the role of international justice
and a major figure in the fight against
corruption and organized crime
while working towards the further
democratization of Croatia which
includes asserting the human rights of
all Croatian citizens and particularly
protecting those of national minorities
he has sought not only to modernize the
institutions of the state but also to
strengthen the security of its citizens
and to develop the economy in the
context of future European Union
membership today President you'll see
povitch will address our forum on the
subject of transitional justice and
international responses to war crimes
please please join me in welcoming to
Columbia University President you'll see
privileged
ladies and gentlemen distinguished
professors and students I'm really
honored to be here and I'm grateful for
you to opportunity to address you my
today's topic transitional justice war
crimes are very important from the
regional from for country when I'm
leaving during the war croatia suffered
heavy heavily I'm very proud that
Croatia defended its independence but
I'm also sorry for every lost life in
the cruel war war in the former
Yugoslavia so I would like to remain you
about the former Yugoslavia as a
unfortunate state failed state and on
this map I pointed out one small place
if you can see it yes this small place
is called named baska voda my
grandmother lived there from 1902 till
ninety 2002 and this place was very
related and she haven't moved any where
she stayed for the whole life in this
very small place but she changed seven
countries seven states she was citizen
of after Hungarian Imperium state of
slovenian squats and serbs kingdom of
yugoslavia italy independent state of
croatia during the war it was pro-nazi
state then socialist federative republic
republic of yugoslavia and then modern
croatia so she haven't moved for a mile
from from this small place but featuring
seven countries and they tell you about
this because it shows how this area is
fragile fresher always or very often
these changements of the state where
accompanied by the
wall by atrocities bar by very
unfortunate historical events so you can
see here composition of former
Yugoslavia composed of many nations many
different cultures different histories
and accretion creations were mostly in
present republic of croatia partly in
bosnia-herzegovina there is racial
minority in serbia as well there are
some very mixed area especially in
boston hetsig arena so you have data
about former yugoslavia and the war was
wrong timing wrong a long-lasting world
with many atrocities and many victims
and now there are seven newborn states
slovenia croatia bosnia herzegovina
montenegro former Republic former
yugoslav republic of macedonia you know
this quarrel about the name with Greece
Serbia and newborn state Kosovo not
recognized by Serbia and some other
countries but I will not discuss those
topics i will discuss war war crimes you
can see some photos from the world the
original so the war lasted agree she
from 1991 till 1995 and then another
three years of reintegration of the
eastern slavonia part of croatia that
was occupied during the war aggression
and territorial claims toward croatia is
represented and about twenty six percent
of creation affair ettore was under
occupation the fights were on fifty four
percent of creation territory and
alluring 36 of each population there are
different estimation about killed person
but number of 23
thousand five hundred looks realistic
there were about 15 and 500,000 killed
people on Croatian side and about 8,000
on Serbians side namely us love army
local para military and civilians as
well there were many wounded persons and
a really important number of refugees
even still now we have to face with this
problem we have to enable to all
creation citizen to come back especially
the biggest group of refugees he'll
placed in Republic of Serbia there were
180,000 destroyed buildings and quarter
of croatian economy was destroyed the
territorial integration was completed in
1998 so what is the war crime there are
different definitions of war crime there
is definition in broader sense it's
violation of fundamental values
individual collective recognized by
international community in the context
of armed conflicts that is using Bella
and legal it is about war crimes crimes
against humanity genocide and different
offenses in national legislations of
course we always ask is there any
responsibility for the war for
aggression yes in some national
legislation ICC settled in their statute
crime of aggression but not functioning
yet because definition of aggression is
still open in international community
what during the history societies has
different answers or different response
to war crimes first response is no
response theory of forgetting everything
was very present because many of people
think that it's better not to think
about it not to generate new quarrels
you
frustration then there is theory of war
and love everything is allowed in war in
love but it's obviously wrong theory
then history is full of Justice of the
winner usually during the history winner
of the war prosecuted the other side
then there is national approach most of
most of legislation national legislation
has appropriate criminal offense is
connected to the war crimes there is
special approach in South Africa they
have and they had truth commission it
was very interesting because it's some
kind of combination between
responsibility and reconciliation I will
not enter detail but it was very
interesting experience not applicable in
the other cartridge or most other
countries and there is of course
international justice and they will tell
you a little bit more about this
international drug justice has
historical attempt there were some
ancient procedures starting from 13th
century in Europe Versailles Treaty
nimble Tokyo then we have experience of
the ad hoc tribunals for former
Yugoslavia and for Rhonda and so-called
mixed or internationalized courts and
tribunals in Cambodia is team or Sierra
Leone Lebanon casa one Boston
herzegovina that means this is in those
cases judiciary is some kind of
combination between local judges and
prosecutors and international judges are
prosecuted of course there is another
approach where you are supported by more
than hundreds I think now hundred and
ten countries this is project of
international criminal court
unfortunately not supported by major
countries like United States Russia
India China and the other but very
supported by European Union
so there are many historical factors
that contributed to the present
situation and development but we can
recognize several trends its move from
collective towards individual
responsibility then from personal
immunity of rulers Kings presidents
generals to personal responsibility from
selectivity that means different
versions of victories justice to
universality that is attempt by icc then
from the purely national approach to the
international justice and from political
criteria responsibility towards legal
criteria yes opponents always stressed
that this international justice is just
for small countries that very important
and very strong countries are not
subject to international justice and
there is Roman quote quality govt
non-lethal Bobby pronounced as a supreme
supreme rule of international criminal
law I would like to see this rule
changed the road to Rome was very long
it was very slow lasting from ancient
times till present days and the fight
for the universal justice is not
finished obviously this fight is going
to be continued you can see here many
historical data on responsibility on
thoughts on war and responsibilities
from from Plato Aristotle Cicero about
universal natural law Hammurabi laws Sun
sank two extra for military even from
Muhammad during his period what's
characteristic for this period is that
there are just fragments just thought
about
possibility and the fact that not
everything is allowed in the wall then
we have another period lasting till 18th
century we have first attempt to
prosecute internationally prosecute some
people like it was case with with
charged terrible Duke that was sentenced
to bed because of his war experiments
there are first agreements bilateral
agreements like within France and
Britain like between US and Russia then
there is the third but very important
period because there are first important
international cover conferences it with
period especially he'd hate conferences
and the basis of international
international law on war was established
in this period I will not go into detail
because I know that not many lawyers are
among you so I will concentrate on the
other things the road to Rome was
decisively moved in the world war after
the world for war first it was
Versailles Treaty and visiting
responsibility of Wilhelm the second
there was the one important case a bit
before the Supreme Court in life secrets
and Rivera castle case then for the
first time very strict and very serious
criteria on responsibilities were
settled before one national quote it was
some kind of pressure to the Germany to
settle this type of court and they
performed it not very good in the other
cases at this land Rivera castle case
was very important because it was adult
property then the first convention was
with
the the international tribunal it was
Convention on terrorism but it was
rectified just by one country just india
decided to support international court
in that time after the Second World War
you know everything about Berg Tokyo
very important case it's a whole
yamashita case because it generates
present concept of comedy responsibility
then there were many activities in UN
framework and then the international
community created ad hoc tribunals for
former Yugoslavia and Rwanda and finally
the ICC the ICTY I will not speak about
criminal responsibility for war crimes
in in the war in Croatia and the other
countries of warm Yugoslavia so the icty
was the reaction of international
community to violence and war crimes
during the war in former Yugoslavia and
after many resolutions and many warnings
from international community atrocities
didn't stopped and the reaction of
security council was to establish the
ICTY international tribunal with several
important tasks firstly the icty had was
created to punish war criminals of
course then to hold leaders accountable
no impunity for readers then to
establish historical facts to develop
international law and what's very
important to bring justice to victims
for the first time victims were focused
as subjects in this type of criminal
proceeding some of those ambitions are
or were realistic some of them not
completely and I think that punishing
war criminals was performed good but
impartial unfortunately many were
criminals stayed on a large at large
the icty made some choice between many
crib war criminals and people from the
area not often very satisfied with this
choice the reason for this restriction
is obviously limited mandate mandate
limited by time and by means also the
ambition to establish the facts is not
very realistic because historians can
explore facts and the tribunals have a
methodology that it's not appropriate
Phylly because it's formed by needs of
parties in the in the appropriate case
so the result is not always the best and
then care for victim is much better than
before and there is special treatment of
it before the ICTY and this is very very
special topic we can probably discuss it
later so what was done by the icty 161
person was indicted there were trials
against more than hundred persons some
cases have been referred to national
courts some are still pending and two
important persons are still at large
radka knowledge and courage hajjaj
outspoken war criminals in the area
there were 64 sentences some acquittals
withdrawals and already 31 persons of
the punishment so is it enough or is not
enough we can discuss it but that's it
and what was the price look at the price
to sentence about 100 person
international community spent nearly two
billion u.s. dollars the price is very
high and there are some thought that it
better to invest this money in region
than in international justice I'm not in
line because I think that results and
consequences from the icty are really
valuable for our societies so what was
done in Croatia up to now we initiated
3638 criminal proceedings cases we have
about 320 ongoing investigations and
more than 1300 cases were dismissed then
we have about 1800 accused persons and
guilty verdicts in 567 cases and not
guilty in 701 case if you compare this
number with number in ordinary cases
when public prosecutor has success in
about eighty-five percent of cases then
you can easily conclude that war crime
cases are not typical typical adult
impression for the very beginning from
the very beginning there were objections
that creation judiciary was not
impartial that people of Serbian origin
were treated differently than Croatian
accused and yes that was the fact that
the very beginning but we had very
intensive activities of the Supreme
Court who corrected this practice and
now under all estimation Croatian
justice is proper one we have very well
equipped
coach specialized for war crimes and now
we have more karate indicted before
those specialized courses and serves
it's very interesting and not always
satisfying for our public opinion but
now we are prosecuting war crimes
properly the reason why we have more
courage than serviceable quote is that
people of Serbian origin escaped from
Croatia and mostly left to Serbia but
there is a big change meant before
several years it was not possible to
think about cooperation about
cooperation between Croatia and Serbia
Croatia most ahead to govern in criminal
cases but obviously it's different time
there is special agreement between
Croatia and Serbia public prosecutors
from pration from Serbia and from
Croatia and Bosnia Herzegovina to
cooperate and then this excellent
cooperation established by appropriate
countries resulted for many new properly
dealt cases and now we have special
results of course so numbers croatia
requested from serbia in 26 cases to
cooperate against fifty two persons some
of them were refused because sabine
authorities so that there are no ground
for it but Sabine authorities accepted
24 cases and it resulted in some
verdicts guilty verdicts in nine cases
and ten of them are still pending so the
cooperation between public prosecutor's
office in Creations we are not
appropriate and as there is a big and
important
move in quality in Croatia that is
appropriate one in Serbia as well
because in Serbia they established
special tribunal for war crimes and
organized crime and this Tribunal is
doing very well so crochet is not only
obliged to cooperate and to prosecute
war crimes just big just by its own laws
and legislation but because of EU
demands as well there are political
criteria to join penn toffee you and
there are settled down in many european
documents and croatia is really
improving its legal system many laws
that change many courts were modernized
and now be improving our legal system in
relatively satisfied manner also
regional cooperation is very important
especially because organized crime is
Without Borders criminals were
cooperating during the war even during
the war and now they are cooperating
better than states and now the states
are trying to catch them that's good
approach so considering the
responsibility for war crimes there was
a mixture of standards at the very
beginning of my speech I mentioned
yamashita case yamashita case is very
important because it's settled special
type of responsibility for commanders
and this type of responsibility is in
contradiction with European criminal law
tradition not Croatian European criminal
law tradition and of course it was that
was always questioned whether we can
apply this type of responsibility even
if we change register
because of principle known criminal
apenas in LA there are several types of
individual responsibility responsibility
of offender that commander superior
responsibility and something special
three types of joint criminal enterprise
this type of responsibility is not
settled in the statute of the icty but
it's practiced by the prosecutor and in
one or two cases by trial chambers what
is the contradiction between this type
of criminal responsibility and and
European legal tradition due to European
legal tradition they must that we have
been yourself description of the crime
act and it detect must be illegal the
consequence must be also illegal and
there must be connection linkage between
the act and the consequence it's easy to
establish relations between act or an
act and consequence in two types of
responsibilities of command esscom
responsibility but in third one it's not
so easy you can see the article 7 of the
icty statute and here down red is shown
the third type of responsibility the
situation that the commander didn't
perform crime he didn't plan the crime
he didn't even you know whether his
soldiers are going to perform the cry
but later he later he
didn't take appropriate measure to
punish to punish songs so the main
question is is the commander responsible
because he's bad commander he didn't
know what is going to happen or he is
responsible for killing rape or the
other crime in the European tradition he
will be responsible for being bad
commander not performing properly his
notice but under the doctrine of common
responsibility based on yamashita case
he is responsible for rape killing and
the other illegal illegal acts so this
difference was basis also for the
political consideration about whether it
is good or necessary to cooperate George
icty or creation and the other countries
should ignore international court a
creation history has several steel
stages infra stage Croatia somehow
somehow obstructed in international
justice and it this stage finished in
two thousand later all creation
governments literally operation
government supported for cooperation
with the icty and later especially
prosecutor a calendar contest stated
that Croatia is fully cooperating now
these days we have gained one problem
with prosecutor brahmers he's asking for
artillery files and now I'm very
involved in this topic and I can clearly
show you that croatian government does
not have this files probably they were
they were destroyed previously and that
was judged also by the trial chamber so
it was from that croatia is not hiding
anything
and precious fully cooperating now so
what was the result of international law
and the practice of the icty there were
very positive results quality of local
judiciary because we really made our
judiciary better especially applying
international law quality of our
legislation is also better they changed
Criminal Code to apply international
standards we also benefit from it there
is new attitude towards the crime among
our citizens because at the very
beginning of criminal proceedings direct
order just the other side performed war
crime was not the fact and then some of
prosecutions contributed reconciliation
in the region but there are some also
negative sides or manipulation political
manipulation by international justice
negative emotions generated in some
cases wrong understanding the nature
goals and the results of this ICT while
and obviously problems with the European
Union we have because there were two
cases obstructing our membership one was
so called the tour in a case when
Croatia was blamed too high general
gotovina but later it was found that he
was in Spain not in Croatia and this
artillery file case when finally that
trial chamber stated that pressure did
everything to fulfill all requirements
but our membership efforts EU membership
efforts were postponed because of those
two cases thank you very much
good morning ladies and gentlemen my
name is John MIT skill and I'm going to
handle the questions and answer session
so I invite anyone who has a question to
step up to the microphones identify
yourself and ask your question hello
please Thank You mr. president my name
is yaad na maani from the Columbia
Business School my question is regarding
this civil society during the war how
were their reactions within the social
internal social security in there were
filings between probably different
militias or different parties but how
were the civilians living are were they
living within peaceful circumstances or
they were very affected by the
atrocities that were going on because
I'm asking you this question because I
come from Lebanon and we suffered also
from a long civil war but during that
war even though there were many
Fighting's on the lines of fire but
within civil societies there was a lot
of solidarity between people and they
were there weren't a lot of robberies
murders that were outside of the war
like personal for person personal motive
and so on so I'd like to know what the
circumstances were in Croatia thank you
firstly in Croatia we didn't have civil
war it was aggression against pressure
supported by some Croatian citizen among
our soldiers patient soldiers we have
many people from serology so they
defended their country as well there
were many unfortunate people sent from
the other areas of former Yugoslavia
especially for Serbia from Serbia to
fight against Croatia some of them
unfortunately were killed that's the
nature of the war and now so many years
after the war we can say that we are
sorry for every lost life during the war
the situation on the territory of
Croatia was not same in every part we
had part of Croatia the
which I probably I can show you on the
map no my map is ok so there were
firstly we had occupied part of Croatia
it was it can you see it was West this
part of Slavonia that means eastern part
of Croatia and it was so called China
region region starting from from Norton
dalmatia I cannot see that the pointer
yes there was this this part of pressure
this part of Russia and it was on this
part the terror against non-stop
operation was very significant there
were also some part of Croatia when
Serbian population didn't have proper
treatment as bad we have to admit
especially when some part of our
territory was deliberated but during the
whole war we had we had civil society
organized to fight for liberties and
human rights we had many NGOs fighting
to help people no less from Bosnia from
Serbia from Croatia especially those
displaced persons and there was a huge
humanitarian aid supported supplied by
by foreign countries by NGOs by
international community and we are
really grateful for this in towns like
Zagreb life was relatively normal
relatively normal and yes there were
some cases of fights between civilians
not motivated by the war but
bye-bye some kind of personal quarrels
and different points of view personal
matters but it was not mess mess messy
so generally speaking it's surprising
how the life in Croatia during the war
was relatively normal the government did
really most efforts to ensure people to
live normally and it was not always
possible in all area because you know
they what happened in booth over what
happened in notin not in part of the
lanesha so that there are many many
really many civilian victims thank you
very much um hello my name is Rocco
Tamara of columbia college and first of
all let me just say Dada say well Carla
um my question is regarding the
connection with EU and the response to
war crimes of course the accession to EU
is one of the primary goals of the
creation government but in Croatia there
is a fairly big amount of euro
scepticism connected exactly to the
response to war crimes so as our
president what would you what concrete
steps would you take to reassure the
population that um the accession to the
EU is a good thing yes at the very
beginning of our European efforts EU
membership had support about more than
eighty percent of citizens but little by
little year by year the support was
lower and now it's about fifty three
percent against are about 38 and the
rest is not certain about the role the
skepticism is partly caused in my
opinion by delay because many of our
citizens think that comparing the other
former socialist countries that crazy
already deserve to be member
and it's some kind of protest against
different criteria but we have to
understand that Europe has the right to
that'll criterion we have to fulfill one
of criteria is judiciary judiciary
justice and regional cooperation among
the other questions justice and
judiciary means also proper treatment of
war crimes and as I told in the first
phase in two thousand our judiciary was
not ready to deal with war crimes
properly but after 2000 all the
government's right left they really
contributed to the changement of the
approach personally I entered the policy
very late then bedtime up to two
thousand three I was part of NGOs I was
run a founder of creation Law Center's
center fighting for responsibility and
for equal criteria before the code I
even wrote the manual for the angels
controlling proceeding in Croatia
documented very well-known organization
now they're making the reports referring
about good and bad things but their
reports are much better better and
better every year so the connection is
very clear Europe does not want the
country which courts are not able to
prosecute and to deal with the most
serious crimes in human history thank
you thank you president first thank you
very much for coming here I think that
none of us saying a wildest dreams
thought we but I hear about
international justice on the president
of Croatia so thank you my name is the
Moldavian from Israel I'm a business
school student and my question is about
the Middle East somebody who's seen one
with his own eyes and nose about justice
what do you think is the future of the
region I already have a second question
Croatia is going to compete with Israel
over
over a place in the European soccer
championship I wonder what you think
he's going to win the the second
question is very easy one Horatio be I
think you still I think it still stand a
chance I have good luck if Croatia ever
as good in other things as in soccer we
will be like Swiss or but the time will
come I'm very optimistic about Croatian
future concerning Middle East as in our
region everything depends on you on your
good will on your capacity to negotiate
on your capacity to accept the other
side as a partner it's not always easy
our example alternate till yesterday we
had war with Serbia now we have common
group intergovernmental groups settling
many different issues from borders to
disappeared persons we have excellent
cooperation between police forces and
public prosecutor offices can you
imagine cooperation between Israeli and
Palestinian when Palestinian side ask
Israeli government to prosecute one
general because his war criminal you
cannot imagine it but now it's on the
table in our region we are cooperating
in prosecution of war criminals i met
your president nearly two months ago
something like this he was he visited
the other and he's really great
politician I admire him and his thoughts
about negotiations are very important
negotiations are the only answer to the
conflict and from as a friend of Israel
as a friend of Palestinian people as
well I really support negotiations and
dissolution about two states looks me
very good so good luck because it is
much easier to negotiate if needed 400
years then have just one day of the war
thank you about basketball no it's a nun
soccer oh thank you my name is Philip
add edits and I'm a PhD student at New
York University just downtown and I
would like for you to briefly discuss
the complicated legacy and roll of one
of your predecessors dr. Frank Koosman
who on the one hand is considered the
father of the modern Croatia but a most
notably from the Serb side accused of
being a war criminal as somebody who
initiated and took steps for that
Croatia to be served free of course the
view on the history cannot be the same
from all sides for creations President
Putin was father of the country he was
our first president I was his political
opponent always but appreciate his his
role in our history he was not perfect
fun I criticized him many times in
Croatia but I hesitate to criticize him
abroad all of us knows that not
everything he did was good enough
but in the history will say that he
founded Croatian State my objections on
his period is concerning treatment of
some atrocities the other objection is
about unappropriate privatization in
during the war and thirdly he was not
champion of human rights but he's now
history we appreciate his positive side
historians will criticize his negative
side as for the other leaders in the
human history thank you thank you
president newsy good you're super bitch
for coming today and for your commitment
to regional Rickett reconciliation and
justice I'm interested in knowing your
advice for leaders of the region of the
former Yugoslavia particularly in regard
to transitional justice future regional
integration okay one of my main goals in
foreign policy is to increase
cooperation between countries in the
region so immediately after I entered
the office I had first meeting with
Serbian president college with Slovenian
president fear and win with Bosnia
leaders and one of important topics is
obviously how to deal with war crimes I
was happy to recognize that all leaders
now leaders in individual are
devastating to cultural of
responsibility and what happened in
Croatia that means the improved our
criteria we improve our judiciary to
prosecute properly volcra war criminals
something similar happened in Serbia as
well they have special court in Serbia I
was there I even participated sorry in
education of judges when I was professor
then I didn't have idea to be President
and they're doing good job their
cooperation between Croatian and Serbian
public prosecutor is very good the same
situation is in Bosnia and Herzegovina
inspired bosnia-herzegovina is really
complicated state really it's not easy
to manage boston herzegovina they're our
friends we have the longest border in
bosnia-herzegovina we have historical
common historical roots common history
but situation is both a successor govern
is not easy they have so-called mixed
mixed judiciary there the court of
bosnia-herzegovina is composed of
national and international judges like
in Kosova as well not not the same but
similar and their feelings about war
criminals are the same as in Croatia as
a diss describe Montenegro as well
montenegro was participating in
aggression against croatia especially
the Montenegrin soldiers were very
active in attack on dubrovnik area but
after many years they also change or
their position and they are prosecuting
several people participated in tekken
dubrovnik so obviously attitude towards
war crimes in whole region is changed
more or less but it's changed and the
future will be very high criteria for
judiciary and very very appropriate
approach and punishment of war criminals
hi my name mr. president my name is yoga
wheels I'm stealing from Belgium and I'm
interested in the side
stern European region and I wanted to
ask you a question about the border
dispute with slovenia and when do you
think the arbitrary agreement on the
border dispute will be signed and how
this issue connects to the ecological
fisheries zone that is established in
the Adriatic Sea mm-hmm so the dispute
is about this base here pearance key
azalea or cebu Driscoll has been
distinguished we are convinced that
under international law Croatia has
appropriate borders now Slovenians
things differently it was long lasting
dispute and Slovenia blocked our
membership efforts trying to force
pressure to accept solutions that change
borders fortunately there was I was not
very happy at the very beginning at
myself I was then Member of Parliament I
thought that it would be done better
from precious odd but now it's out of
any question it was very important
agreement with in Croatian Prime
Minister scarcer and Slovenian Prime
Minister are under European out pieces
of obviously that this border dispute
will be resolved by international
arbitration and what's very important
application will take place after
creation enters to EU that means it will
not influence the process that's very
important than that's somehow fair fair
agreement so is something that can be
applied in similar situation all around
the world follow me Alabama thank thank
you president for coming to columbia um
my name is Bob son I'm student from
Canada
and I was wondering about the future of
the ICC because many people see it now
especially without the sport of the
great I guess the more influential
nations like the US as not very well run
as being very slow to prosecute people
how do you see that improving going
forward this project is very important I
consider it as one of the most pros
multipotent progress in human history
but obviously situation in which
Americans Russians Chinese Indian
country India and Indonesia that means
majority of the world is out of the
project situation is not good enough
especially I have the treasure I was
disappointed by American position
because especially in our countries in
Southeast Europe in Eastern Europe
America was considered as a champion of
democracy human rights and everything
possible during the wrong conference
croatia was part of so-called
like-minded group that one group led by
Canada Argentina European countries very
favor establishment of the code from the
other side there were some countries
trying to abstract this and the result
was very positive you know I think 120
something like this conscious voted for
and the other countries especially those
big countries were against fortunately
later president clinton signed the women
but President Bush designed it and I
hope that the time will come for all
countries to participate a little bit
joking I said that this Tribunal will be
proper one when the first British
American Russian Chinese French General
stands before this tribunal because if
the tribunal is just for small or not so
strong country then
project is not completed but the history
is before us we have hundreds and
thousands of years and I very convinced
that in future we'll have our planet
without the wars and with responsibility
for atrocities thank you the Varden mr.
president my name is Petra so ditch and
I'm a Columbia School of International
and public affairs graduate student my
question to you is regarding
international justice which you spoke at
length about and it's connected to civil
society in our country and specifically
in terms of how do you think that
international justice in the way that
it's viewed within Croatia will affect
the memory of the war and its progress
when you're young colleague asked me
about president judgment I already told
that history is not stone monument equal
for everyone history is seen differently
from different people different nations
and it's very important to move our
vision of history towards reality
basically I think our approach to
history to the world that happened on
the character former Yugoslavia is very
new or very near to reality when we say
yes we had we defended our country and
we liberated our country but when we
speak about war crimes we are not always
realistic there were war crimes on all
sides not in equal numbers but the crime
is crime and the role of civil society
was and is very important during from
the very beginning of the Horde ever
many NGOs like creation Law Center
which I was 10 pounder or Natasha candy
chill in Belgrade or circles around
women movement in Sarajevo or the other
I can I can croatia Helsinki Committee
as well fighting against violations of
international humanitarian law trying to
establish religious truth there is no
peace without justice this also the name
of our very important organization and
the stro reconciliation means also to
accept yesterday unacceptable part of
our history we have to face we have to
face it it necessary it must be done
also by our neighbors especially by them
because I think not always the role of
different persons and states during the
war is recognized in our neighborhood
and it's very important because those
countries those people those nations who
cannot recognize the history are always
impaired to repeat to repeat mistakes
from the history mistakes or settled all
around the region but it's very clear
what was the reason of the war and war
started and who's who in the war but the
whole criminals were occupying all
territory for me was like uh huh hi I'm
Ava frenzy forum partner college and you
spoke about increasing minority rights
but I'm wondering
you justify the policy of allowing
citizens in bosnia-herzegovina who are
ethnically kirat to vote in parliament
even though they tend to be the ones who
are most against minority rights okay so
uh during presidential campaign we had
presidential election even Boston heads
ago and I do know how many would say
gaining in bosnia-herzegovina in whole
Boston hetaloid four percent 96% was
gained by my opponent but I want
elections with high majority and in
spite i got one just four percent in
bosnia-herzegovina i defend the right of
those people because they're citizens of
croatia to participate especially having
in mind historical circumstances in
principle yes it will be better not to
mix our votes from country to the
country but it's in this stage of our
history when most of people there or are
moving from the other from one side of
the border to the other but there are
many displaced persons especially from
post arena before the war there were two
hundred twenty thousand krotz living in
poor sorry nights this area so
unfortunately I cannot see it's can you
see the no yeah pasadena is here this
part of bosnia-herzegovina now mostly
Republican cells canal so there were two
thousand two two two two hundred twenty
thousand flights living there now there
are 25,000 and they are living the in
Croatia here and there so and those
people feel some kind of security in
participation mr. president thank you
for coming and speaking with us today I
greatly appreciate it my name is Brian
Morgan I'm a better united states marine
corps and currently a student here at
home University School general studies
you mentioned during your presentation
that
after the war a large number of Serbians
who would have been prosecuted under the
icty fled the region which does led to a
disproportionate number of prosecutions
against Croatian citizens as opposed to
Serbians my question to you sir is how
has this inequality of prosecution among
Croatians infected the support overall
for the icty and do you see as a problem
moving forward for further prosecutions
mm-hmm I'll show you again the numbers
and the answer is in numbers let me let
me show you yes up so the criminal
prosecution against alleged war criminal
started in nineteen ninety one obviously
creation bodies will motivate to
prosecute really heavy crimes performed
by other side by aggressor saw and
during all these warriors there are
cases and cases and later because on
especially on occupied territories there
were no proper registration of packets
and obviously there were many cases that
started about 3600 but look at this
number from 360 this devil 1300
dismissed cases there were more not
guilty sentence that give the sentence
and in the other cases eighty percent of
verdicts are guilty that means different
criteria were applied motivated by
suffering during the war people were
accused to participate everyone who was
known as participant in some Serbian
forces was in position to be accused and
after many of those people left Croatian
went to Serbia they were
many trials in absentia and analyzes of
this cases shows that there were no
doubt proper and then it was recognized
by our public computers and most of
those dismissed cases are those cases
that held in absentia so real number of
war crime cases is much lower than 3600
because few years ago public prosecutor
took all war crime cases make a revision
of them and this maced a really big
number that's good because many of
refugees living now in Serbia can easily
easier decide to come back to preach
because they are not afraid of
persecution anymore thank you sir good
afternoon good afternoon mr. Fitch and
thank you my name is ayanna Witter
Johnson I'm from London and I would like
to find out how your musicianship
influences your leadership well it's not
easy to answer if I were conductor it
will be much easier but I'm composer
probably that's also good I can compose
something good for our country I cannot
recognize direct connection between my
musical interest and presidency but i
guess that art is making people better
probably I'm not good enough but music
is making me better and probably future
I'll be good person and good president
and that can just contribute the the
role of individual I would like to see a
lot of politician listening music
playing composing drawing writing books
because i really think that art is
people bet thank you thank you thank you
ladies and gentlemen thank you president
your C privilege for stimulating Thank
You discussion and we hope to see you at
Columbia very soon thank you